all right so we're gonna get started
here thank you everybody for coming out
and thanks everybody who is returning
I'd like to acknowledge some of our
sponsors here so obviously num focus
like to thank them for sponsoring this
monthly meetup as well as TD Ameritrade
who is my employer for offering up this
wonderful venue as well as to Midas for
supplying the food for this Meetup
if you are if you work here if you work
at University of Michigan or you're you
indirectly over at Midas or meet Nunn
focus people I pie data events please do
thank them as well a couple important
points for people who are new here
emergency exists there's one right
behind this white board here as well if
you walked out these doors that you came
through on the right hand side right
before the elevators there's stairs that
go down we're always looking for
speakers in the future we do have a
great lineup lined up all the way out
until November maybe December we're
always trying to get ahead of that
because it always makes me nervous
when I don't have people lined up gives
me lessons up anxiety but also please
provide any feedback things that we're
doing great not-so-great things that we
can do to improve that diversity and
inclusion that'd be fantastic as well
we're always open to hearing you can
email me message me on the meetup group
also unless you have quick questions try
to please hold them until the end I'm
sure that we have a lot of engaged
people here but let's try to keep the
keep the long ones until the end and
also remember that we're in a board
space so try to clean up after
yourselves your plates your cups the
garbage cans are over by where the food
is I'd like to quickly go over our short
version of the PI data code of conduct
so PI data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free conference experience
for everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of conference
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any conference venue including talks
be kind to others do not insult and put
down other attendees behave
professionally
remember that harassment and sexist
racist or exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate from high data attendees
violating these rules may be asked to
leave the conference without a reef
without any further explanation and it
is at the sole discretion of the
conference organized or the meetup
organizers but overall thank you for
help making this a welcoming and
friendly environment for everybody if
anybody does encounter any problems
please do do let me know ah quick
icebreaker so I tried to come up with
one earlier and maybe the back story is
that I found poison ivy at my house
so I want to know if turn to somebody to
your left or to your right hopefully
some that you haven't met before
introduce yourselves and tell them
whether or not you've experienced the
effects of poison ivy poison oak poison
sumac any of that so
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so hopefully you know the talk
gonna be great but hopefully you will
have met somebody that you have not met
before
and you learned something new this month
in data science I like to plug this if
anybody is interested in podcasts
especially in the data science realm
this is a great new podcast called data
frame coming out from the folks over at
data camp which is a data science online
training courses we're actually going to
have the we've invited the I guess
interviewer update afraid to come give a
talk in the fall so I feel go about Van
Anderson so that's gonna be a lot of fun
but definitely check out this this
podcast it comes out on a weekly basis
and interviewing sort of data scientist
from different backgrounds whether it's
academia industry so give it a listen
also TD Ameritrade is hiring so if
anybody is looking for either a position
speak to a logan ahlstrom I think he's
floating around somewhere I might be in
the back there so definitely go talk to
him so they're looking for data
scientist whether it's junior or senior
positions as well as data analyst on
their team and I also want to point out
a new Meetup
there's our friends over in Toronto
which is where I whacked him from has
they just started the PI D de Toronto
meetup group so go check them out if
you're ever in the area and last but not
least would like to plug our next event
so on Thursday July 19th we have skipper
Sebold coming from civis analytics from
Chicago and he's good he's going to be
talking to us about what's the science
in data science so please do sign up and
come up to that event and so with that
I'm gonna introduce our speaker for
today it is uh Leland McGuinness who
hails originally from New Zealand but is
now currently working in Ottawa Canada
so another fellow Canadian and he works
at the Institute and today he's gonna be
telling us about that mentality
reduction and so I meant leaving a
couple of years ago and we should be
learning a lot today all right good
evening I want to say thank you first of
all to Sean and the organizers of this
event it's really great to get invited
here you have had many many very eminent
speakers in the past and I am very
flattered to get the invitation so PCA
tease me and you map is what you'll hear
today but first of all who am I so I'm a
researcher and mathematician from the
Tata Institute for mathematics and
computing my PhD wasn't something you do
not care about it is bizarre pure mess
the takeaway here is that I'm really a
mathematician I'm not actually a machine
learning guy I work with a lot of really
awesome people some of whom do know
machine learning really well and so I
get to work with them and together we
can build a great team that actually
does useful stuff so that's the
background so what is dimension
reduction and why would you want to do
it anyway so the core idea of the
introduction is to find that the latent
hidden features in your data there's
this idea that there should be some some
background features that tell you
something about your data so what does
that mean well feature engineering is
another way to think about it and that's
a really important task finding the core
features that are important is how to
think about it or if you reduce down to
two dimensions you can visualize with a
scatterplot so visualization feature
engineering these are important tasks
and this is why some of the reasons you
want to do to make sure to action so
here is an example of the first hundred
of the illness digits data set they're
handwritten digits so there are 28 by 28
pixel grayscale images of handwritten
digits now if you take each digit you
can unfold that 28 by 28 matrix into a
784 dimensional vector now the key here
is that I shouldn't really need 784
dimensions to be able to describe digits
there should be some smaller latent
space that can describe these digits
efficiently without having to
you sold 794 dimensions here's another
example we're going to be working with
here are images from fashion illness
this is made to be a drop-in replacement
for the illness digit status it's
there's a little more challenging than a
minister fitness to be honest it's it's
kind of an old entire data set by this
point so these are images of fashion
items like shoes t-shirts bags and so on
and again these end up being 794
dimensional vectors and really we
shouldn't need that many dimensions to
describe this data so that's that's the
core here so the next thing is how does
one go about doing dimensional reduction
and really there's actually only two
ways you are there do it by a matrix
factorization or by a neighbor graphs
now how you do these things is what
matters
matrix factorization really means a
whole slew of different specific
algorithms principal component analysis
linear autoencoders even we're too thick
and glove for text and hitting amount to
matrix factorization what it comes down
to is what matrix you construct a factor
and the sort of lost and regularization
you use to do that matrix factorization
but really there's one core technique
here and that's matrix factorization the
same is true for neighbor graphs there's
a whole slew of different algorithms
what graph do you construct how do you
weight the edges if you're going to
weight the edges how do you lay up that
graph in low dimensions these are all
options and they all need to slightly
different algorithms and there are a
whole slew of different algorithms but
they all come down to the same core
thing which is really building a graph
and then bidding that graph in a low
space ok so to start with let's look at
principle component analysis because
this is the prototypical matrix
factorization algorithm and I'm going to
talk about it in a way to try to
highlight the similarity of a two sort
of more general matrix factorization so
on that front I want to get a shout out
there's a great paper called generalized
low ranked models by Adele at all go and
read that paper it is a great paper on
general matrix factorization techniques
for dimension reduction if you want to
do two meter reduction by a matrix
factorization it goes through and
provides a code
he's singular view of pretty much all
the different techniques out there in
one simple framework so that's just an
aside but go look at that paper so PCA
is an old algorithm it's been around for
a long time it's the old workhorse of
tension reduction but it's still around
and it's still doing an important job
and it's still inspiring new algorithms
today so one can view it as trying to
reconstruct a data as a linear
combination of some small number of
prototypes so writing that as an
equation here's this thing and I want to
minimize this what does what does that
mean what's going on here well this is
the input data so X by J is the value of
the J feature of the ice sample so
that's some number and then over here is
my approximation to that so U is
actually the low dimensional embedding
that we're going to use that's going to
be a result and V is the sort of matrix
of prototypes if you like that we're
going to build linear combinations of
the matrix multiplication there that
we're doing U times V is matrices just
basically is a shorthand notation or way
of doing this linear combination and
then as a whole we're saying here's the
reconstruction error this is the amount
of error I'm going to multiply u times V
I'm going to get some linear combination
of prototypes and how close is that to
the original data and I'm just going to
take that as the squared error and when
we try and minimize this
that's what PCA is doing now if you
change how you measure the error or
other things you can get all kinds of
other different algorithms but PCA is
really about minimizing this
reconstruction error so what does that
look like in practice in pictures here's
some data it's in two dimensions what
we're going to do is reduce this data to
two dimensions yes we can actually do
that we can go from the same dimensions
to the same dimensions it's it's okay
it'll be a nice pictorial way to see
what's going on so one of the nice
things about this form here is it has a
closed form solution I said it was a
minimization problem I wanted to
minimize this we could
that by an optimization process but
there's a violin area linear algebra a
closed-form solution that just tells you
what the answer should be so what we're
going to get out is the closed form
solution is that the V's are going to be
the directions of maximal variance those
are going to be the prototypes that fall
out of this and if you think about it
that makes a lot of sense I mean if you
want to find the prototypes that are
going to be the best to describe your
data in terms of vector directions the
best direction to describe your data is
the maximal variance direction and then
once you've taken care of that one
what's the next best thing well the next
direction of maximal variance orthogonal
to that and so on so those are going to
be our prototypes so we can think of
those as just victors in air space and
then given some point of our data we're
going to project that onto those V
vectors to get u 1 and u i1 and UI 2
which are error low dimensional and
beating values so those are going to be
the values of air reduced dimensions
sorry is the mic being weird here don't
okay good
so this is what you get out as a result
now we didn't actually do anything here
because we're going from two dimensions
to two dimensions so it looks the same
except we rotated it out but the same
process with hole if we started with a
thousand and twenty four dimensions and
went to it's just we wouldn't perfectly
reconstruct the data anymore because our
approximation we only have two
prototypes to work with it's kind of
sticking a linear plane through those
thousand and twenty four dimensions and
projecting onto that okay so how about
doing that on real data so let's try it
on in this digits I showed you some of
the digits here's 70,000 of them
projected into two dimensions with PCA
and you can see that it actually has
done a good job here I've colored the
the points by the digit that they were
so on the far left you see the ones on
the far right you can see the zeros and
that's your sort of maximal variance
direction and then in the other
direction you
built seven and nine and four down to
two and three and six sort of it's a bit
smeared but you can see and the key here
is that the global structure of the data
has been preserved even though we've
only predicted down to two dimensions
starting with 784 we've predicted to two
dimensions and we still know an awful
lot about this data if we went to a
larger number of again shouldn't say ten
it would still work really well in fact
it'd be bitter and this is the key is
that we can project down to a very small
number of dimensions and still retain a
lot of information about the data oh we
can do it on fashion in list as well it
looks pretty similar again we have sort
of major directions it's sort of
footwear across to everything else and
in trousers up to everything else and in
bags at the top there the blue you can
see okay so how about T distributed
stochastic neighboring bidding so in
2008 TC came along and set a new bar for
doing introduction for visualization
purposes there were a whole bunch of
algorithms that had come out in the
2000s SMF and friends but t-sne came
along and was so much better than all of
them that pretty much everyone ended up
converting pretty quickly now t-sne is
usually explained in terms of
probabilities and some sort of
probability based approach but I'm not
going to do that I'm going to take a
different approach I'm gonna explain in
a different way and it's gonna lead to
algorithms like you math which I'll be
discussing later and for which TV was an
inspiration so I claim that TST can
really be viewed best as a graph based
algorithm instead I'm gonna skip
probabilities and go straight to graphs
so let's build a directed graph and for
the vertices I'm gonna have the data
points that I start with that I want to
reduce the dimension off so here's a
picture so I'm gonna start with the
point in the middle and I'm gonna draw
directed edges to all the neighboring
points now if I just keep doing this I'm
gonna end up with a directed graph
that's a complete directed graph that
has all the possible edges but could
ever be and that's not very informative
but if I instead wait
Agis using an RBF kernel radial basis
functions so that essentially we're
gonna decay so smaller weights get
applied to points that are more distant
from each other then I would get
something like this if I just threw the
edges from that central point where I'm
shading them by effectively the weight
so lower weight for the more distant
points now how do you choose the
bandwidth of that kernel well we can
vary that per point based on sort of an
information theoretic measure is what
t-sne actually uses but it's not worth
getting into the details it's better to
say that that su correlates essentially
with the distance to the cake nearest
neighbor if you like or you can think of
it as related to the total weight that
would be applied to a give an outgoing
vertex okay so next we're going to
normalize all the weights at each vertex
of the total outcome and weight from the
vertex is just 1 ah why would you want
to do this well it's gonna even things
out that weren't caught by that been
with variation trick we just did so we
would end up with something that looks a
bit like this I'm not going to draw all
the edges because it would just be too
difficult to visualize but we're gonna
end up with different way edges and
they're going to be some incoming and
some outgoing so between each pair of
points there's going to be a pair of
edges and importantly those pair of
edges are going to have different
weights because of the different kernel
bandwidths we applied to each point and
the fact that we did that normalization
so there everything's sum to one
independent for each point so what we'd
like to do is convert that to an
undirected graph by just averaging the
weights between pairs of vertices now we
could take the average but if you think
about it we could we could do the max we
could do the min we could do the product
we could do the geometric mean there's a
lot of options but with no other
motivation the arithmetic mean seems
like a perfectly sensible thing to do so
we're just gonna do that and then we're
going to normalize all the weights on
the graph so the total weight of all the
edges in the graph sums up to one now
that doesn't seem a terribly obvious
thing to do but it is in fact critical
and we'll see why in a bit
so we're gonna end up with something
like this it's going to be an undirected
graph with wave the edges now what do we
do with that well suppose we had a
proposed low dimensional and beating of
air points we could use a similar
process to build a way to graph all
those points in the low dimensional
space that we want to embed into we're
to have some differences though this is
just how tsne works first of all we're
not going to use that RBF kernel anymore
we're gonna use a t-distribution kernel
and that's because it has a slightly
different shape and it's going to help
with crowding of points we're going to
fix the bandwidth for all the points
with the high dimensional data for each
data point I chose a different kernel
bandwidth instead I'm going to choose
one fixed kernel bandwidth and have it
for everything and that has the
advantage that means that the whole
thing can be considered an undirected
graph from the start because the edge
weights will be equal in either
direction so I don't need to care the
average will work out to be whichever
one I choose and why did we choose these
particular things it's because they work
well is really the answer I don't have
any good answers for why these
particular choices were made now we want
to build a low dimensional
representation that gives a graph that
matches as closely as possible to the
graph using the high dimensional case
that's really all that's going on here
so if we take a reconstruction error of
this which is an oddly chosen looking
thing from a probability theory point of
view where the original authors built
the algorithm this was an entirely
sensible choice for the graph based
approach it looks odd but it works so
the WHU here is the weight of the edge
in the high dimensional graph the WL is
the weight of the edge in the low
dimensional graph now the goal is to
minimize this error now if you think
about it the wh is fixed because we have
our fixed high dimensional graph and if
we're going to optimize we're going to
move the points around low dimensional
space to try and minimize that
or we could minimize it by basically
making WL as large as possible
now given the nature of the kernel that
means sitting everything to one that
would be fine except for the fact well
what would that mean that would mean we
put everything at just zero from each
other so it's the cool points on top of
each other except we have that
normalization step where we're going to
make the total weight of the graph sum
to one so if I stick everything on top
of it each other then I'm gonna average
that out so everything gets the same
very low weight and in fact I'm gonna
get a bad reconstruction error in that
case so in practice what's actually
happening there is that normalizations
did is providing a kind of universal
repulsive force among the points you
can't squash them too close together to
each other unless the light on the high
initial edge is really large so in
practice that means we have an
attractive force
wherever the whites on the high
dimensional ages are large and a
repulsive force serve just University on
the points so really this is a force
directed graph layout if you've ever
done force directed graph layouts this
is what that is it's just force directed
graph layout for a particular choice of
how to do that force direction so that's
how it works how well does it work in
practice
well here's in this digits with t-sne
and you can see immediately the
difference to PCA PCA had a big smear of
different colors here with picked out
each and every digit pretty cleanly into
nice distinct groups so essentially by
focusing on the local structure it's
managed to understand the lighting
structure of the digits far better than
PCA could PCA was focused on global
structure here we're focusing on local
structure and we've captured far more
information similarly for fashion in
nest
some of the classes are a little jumbled
there but largely it's it's pulled all
the classes apart really cleanly and
it's understood a great deal about the
data so even only projecting to two
dimensions we've understood a lot about
all those images of fashion items
okay so on to uniform metaphor
approximation and projection you map
which is an algorithm I created with
some of my colleagues at the tuff
Institute as an attempt to build
something t-sne like but with firmer
mathematical foundation there was all
that graph based approach that I
described as a way to understand the
algorithm but to some extent from that
line of thought about how to build the
algorithm some of it was not as clearly
motivated so I wanted to motivate the
steps that I was making
so you met builds a mathematical theory
to try and justify this graph based
approach so if we want to think of it in
a graph based way how would we go about
providing the math that justifies that
now for this talk I'm going to gloss
over the Fen CMS it's not though the
method is particularly hard but it uses
a kind of math and language that is
probably less familiar to a lot of
people so it's not worth getting into
the detail the main thing is that we're
going to have a rigorous theory that
makes the decisions about what to do at
various stages in the algorithm for me
and makes it easier to generalize it to
do other things and other problems but
first a little bit of topological data
analysis because that's going to be the
theory that we're going to use to
justify everything we're doing so the
first thing is this notion of simplices
now in practice we're not going to need
really much of this at all but the the
notion matters so zero simplex is just a
point a one simplex can be described by
two points and it is essentially the
line that joins them - simplex is
described by three points and you get a
convex hull three simplex on up the key
here is that this is all purely
combinatorial there is no continuous
space to deal with here everything can
be described in purely finite
combinatorial terms and if you do
topology then this is the way to deal
with topological spaces from anyways
because it takes complex topological
objects which are all continuous and
messy and hard to work with and turns
them into something simple and
in combinatorial so these are simplest
C's if you glue them together you can
get a thing pulled of simplicial complex
now the only real key here is when you
glue them together you have to glue them
together along the faces of the simplest
C's you kind of just stick them together
randomly but the result is that we can
glue them together and make a thing that
is a topological space and the joy here
for apologists is that in practice you
can construct almost any topological
space out of simpler C's in this way so
you can describe almost a lot of
topology in this combinatorial approach
now there are pathological topological
spaces but you're never going to
encounter those with data so it's not
something we need to worry about okay
this is a picture of a theorem you don't
need to read it the main thing is that
there is a theorem that happily says
that we can go from a topological space
to this simplicial complex description
of it and that will capture all the
information we need to understand that
topological space well and that there's
a way to do this and there's solid
mathematical theory that's all very high
fluting and fancy that says that this
works really well okay so in practice
what's going on here we can take some
points and I'm going to color code them
by their position along a manifold which
they were noisily drawn from now I'm
going to build a cover which basically
means I've got to cover the manifold in
some new manner in practice I'm going to
place open bowls of some fixed radius on
each point and now I'm going to take the
nerve of that cover which is really
fancy math terminology for saying I'm
going to stick an edge wherever those
bowls intersected pairwise I'm going to
stick a triangle wherever they Triple E
intersected I'm going to stick a
tetrahedron wherever they quadruple e
intersected and so on up and that's a
simplicial complex that's that's this
blurring together a bunch of simplices
and that here and we had basically says
this captures the topology of the
manifold now if you
it didn't perfectly capture that meta
fault that you probably means lead ruin
and could see for yourself
it has gaps where it's not connected and
there are some parts there where it's
probably you know a little clunkier than
it should be
so what went wrong there well if the
data were uniformly distributed on the
manifold then that cover would be good
that's what we rolled it out it wasn't
uniformly distributed if we go back
there's you know big spaces here where
the dot is spray out more so here's a
picture where I uniformly distributed
the dot on the manifold and lo and
behold if we took the nerve of that we
would get a perfect graph there was a
line and everything would look great we
would have understood everything so all
we need is for the data to be uniformly
distributed on the manifold but when is
data ever that nicely behaved it's just
not that's not how these things work but
as a mathematician I get to assume
whatever I like so let's assume the data
is uniformly distributed on the manifold
case-closed we're good right
not quite there's there's a converse
side of this if we say that the data is
uniformly distributed on the manifold
that actually tells us something about
the manifold so here's where it gets a
little fancy
we have to define a romanian Ettrick on
the manifold to make that assumption be
true that's kind of how it works now
this is a slightly deeper graph but the
key point here is that we're going to
define a notion of distance that varies
from point to point as we move across
the data so here's some quick primer on
meta fault theory what we're really
doing is patching together bits of data
that look like normal Euclidean space so
this is how you build curved spaces and
mathematics you glue together bits of
space that look flat so there are these
convenient maps from some local region
of the space down to just normal
Euclidean space now what you need to
take away from this is that what we're
essentially going to do in effect is say
well in some local patch I'm going to
say that the notion of distance is there
in a different local patch I'm going to
map to Euclidean space in a different
way so that I get a different notion of
distance there so you can do this with
you can push all the math through and
there's a paper online if you want to
look it up but you probably don't and
what you get is this this is this is
that same data and now every single one
of those balls is in fact a unit ball
they don't look like unit balls because
they're not unit balls in the ambient
space the background space but according
to the manifold according to this
varying notion of distance as I move
from point to point to point to point
they are and specifically this is the
notion of distance that is required to
make these points be effectively
approximately uniformly distributed so
we're doing the thing that recovers the
assumption we need to make all the math
work and we're just having to change our
notion of distance on the manifold to do
it and in the end this looks a whole lot
like cane Agri graphs and other standard
manifold learning techniques but why
choose a fixed radius why not have a
fuzzy cutter because there's some
uncertainty here right like I said the
data was uniformly distributed and I got
this notion of distance local to each
point but the further I get from the
point the less sure I am of that notion
of distance because I'm further away
from where I was defining my notion of
distance so shouldn't we so have a fuzzy
topology and a fuzzy cap or something
like that there are many ways we could
do this again here's a picture of a
theorem you don't need to worry about it
the point is that there is actually a
whole bunch of deep underlying math that
says explicitly have to do this
and in fact it says that we can go from
finite metric spaces to fuzzy simplicial
sets and that there's a fixed undefined
way that that should be done correctly
and takes care of all these details so
it's much more rigorous than all the
hand waving I'm doing here and works a
little differently but the intuition is
the same that we can move to ending up
with a fuzzy cover where now instead of
these fixed balls they sort of fade out
as they get further
from the point and now we're doing
something more than just a key neighbor
graph we're making use of that local
notion of distance because the way it
decays depends on that local notion of
distance and if you think about it this
looks a lot like t-sne with its varying
bandwidth for kernels except we have a
method explicit mathematical
justification as to why we assumed that
it was uniformly distributed on the
manifold that told us something about
how to measure distance on the manifold
and now we've just taken a uniform cover
with fixed radius balls that decay in
the way that they have to according to
the math so one more assumption slips in
at about this point which is that the
manifold is locally connected so this is
again fancy math but I'm not saying the
manifold is all connected in one giant
chunk what I'm really saying is that
there are no isolated points that are
off all by themselves
everything is connected to something it
might just be that there's two points
that are connected to each other far
away somewhere and not connected to
everything else but local connection is
an important assumption to make so what
that means in terms of our fuzzy cover
here is you can think of it that we
should be completely confident in air
cover out to the first nearest neighbor
and then after that you can decay and
range off from there now again the fancy
math that I had before actually makes
all that explicit in terms of these a
junctions and how to do that properly
but the practical effect is that we
actually get a greater range of distance
prettier neighbors now here's the
important part
here's a distribution of distances to 20
nearest neighbors for a given data set
where I pick things in two dimensions if
I put them in four dimensions eight
dimensions sixteen dimensions and the
key here is the the distribution of the
distances to 20 nearest neighbors slowly
but surely slides up this distance scale
so that if you were to try and because
really we want everything to end up here
so what you might do is divide out by
the largest thing if I do a
multiplicative division type thing I
mean
squash that distribution to get it near
the origin and it's gonna be really
really really tight I'm gonna local I
have much variation in that distribution
what I'd really like to do is just slide
it along which is essentially subtract
off the distance to the nearest neighbor
that'll slide along to the origin and
we're good so that's what this local
connectivity assumption is doing for us
in practice it's motivated by a pure
theoretical constraint in practice it
provides real difference for high
dimensional data the higher the
dimension the more important this
becomes but I skipped something our
local matrix are all incompatible with
each other so here was the pretty
diagram of the nice theory that was
supposed to work but these maps here Tao
that meant back and forth between the
sort of intersection of the two things
we don't have those we never built them
the theory was we only had finite data
so we had to guess but we don't know how
that works because that's that overlap
occurs where we don't have data so where
we don't have data we don't know what to
do so instead of overlaps we have
disagreements how do we cope with that
well in terms of the graph sense we
essentially end up with multiple edges
with different weights joining two
points which should sound a lot like
what T's in e head so the trick is that
an ear case we can think of this as
trying to glue together a whole family
of different matrix faces that all
disagree with each other there's one for
each point and how do we glue them all
together again that's where this nice
theorem that's again picture of a
theorem tells us exactly what to do
because what we are essentially doing is
translating everything over to this
fuzzy simplicial set land where
everything is combinatorial are nice and
we know exactly what to do we just Union
them all together and so under a
probabilistic fuzzy Union the
combination of weights on edges is given
by not the arithmetic mean of them but
there's some - their product which looks
a little weird but if you think of this
as the probability of an edge existing
is what the white attached to an age is
then what this is really saying is the
this combined value is the probability
of either this age or the CH existing
it's just the or of the two
probabilities so it makes a lot of sense
and in practice it works we end up with
a nice weighted graph but equally
importantly we have the theoretical
justification for why we should build
this particular graph and why it should
look like this
now suppose we were given a low
dimensional representation much like
t-sne we could apply the same process to
get a fuzzy graph except for a couple of
things first we know what the manifold
is I don't have to do this uniform
approximation trick because I know what
the manifold is I want to project it
into Euclidian space so I know my
manifold is Euclidean space and done I
know how to measure distance there
that's all but I don't know what the
correct nearest neighbor distance is we
had that local connectivity assumption
that we were told by the data what that
was when I'm in the low dimensional
space I don't know what that should be
so I have to pick that as a hyper
parameter and so now we just measure the
distance between these graphs using
cross-entropy and then we optimize so
here's the cross entropy formula but
really we're just embedding the graph
it's just a graph layout it's a force
directed graph layout just kind of like
t-sne but a little different so you can
think of it this way this is the get the
Klumps right term and this is what T is
in E head that looks a whole lot like
the TNA term but this this term over on
the right TNA didn't have that and
that's they get the gaps right term
that's a repulsive force but it's a
global repulsive force that works
depending on the values of the data
rather than the uniform repulsion the
t's knee had by the normalization group
and the important point is that by not
normalizing the edges the weightiest
anita is to generate the repulsion this
is all actually much more
computationally tractable
so here's the graph invading we get out
from that and then we would end up with
this as air and meeting in the space
which is not exactly perfect but we did
pull out the line fairly accurately and
then there's the weird guess there and
if you actually look at the the data
here what actually calls that well
there's a dense area of points there in
a deal Serie of points there and that
really missed up air uniform
distribution assumption because there
was a little more density than would be
expected and that would be sold if we
just had more data that it would iron
out some of those kinks so more data
would remedy this so what does this
crazy math algorithm look like on real
data here's in this digits and so again
like ta cee we've picked out all the
digits really cleanly but we've also
captured the same global structure that
PC aided we've got the ones on the left
zeros on the right and we got groups
four seven nine up high eight five three
in the middle that are similar looking
digits and it's grouped them together
independently it's captured global
structure and local structure together
here is fashion in esteem we picked out
all the different groups as well as
t-sne but unlike TNA it's separated off
pence and footwear as being quite far
away and distinct from the other groups
this is this is important we captured
the global structure and the local
structure
alright so implementing this is there's
actually tractable to implement all this
crazy math so when you really boil it
down what we need to do is find
approximate nearest neighbors really
really efficiently even in high
dimensional space but fortunately random
projection trees and nearest neighbor
descent are two algorithms that are
already out there and published that
will tell you how to do this well we
would also need to optimize the layout
and do so in a sub quadratic algorithm
that's fine stochastic gradient descent
and the negative sampling tricks use
some word to Vic in fact are exactly the
tools you need to do this again standard
published tools we just use them it
needs to be built
in a high-level language but still be
fast so I'm not really a programmer I'm
a mathematician I can't write good code
but Python lets me write code that looks
much more like math I can write Python
at least I can't write C++ but number
which is a library that compiles Python
code down into LLVM let's numeric Python
go blindingly fast so I actually can't
say enough good things about number this
was my first project where I really
really used number in anger and it is
awesome it is amazing there is nothing
like it
you should try and use it for your code
honestly so what does it mean well you
get high performance like sea level
performance out of your code but your
code is just really clean simple Python
it doesn't look like the messy size and
stuff if you've ever dealt with syphon
it's really clean really simple and it
allowed me to do crazy things like allow
users to provide custom distance matrix
and have it run just as fast as the
distance matrix that I haven't to write
so you can you can write code in Python
yourself and as long as you can attach a
number get a decorator at the top of
your function you can hand it to my code
and it will run still just as fast as
ever and that's actually an amazing feat
because I have no idea how to do that
inside them I have no idea how to do
that in C++ in C++ I'd say okay write
your function now recompile my entire
library from scratch with your code
included and hopefully it'll work okay
so how about a performance comparison so
this is comparing instead of the art
multi-core t-sne the SK learn to uni is
a little slower than this so this is
even better so the coil 20-day to see it
t-sne took about 20 seconds you have to
do it in seven seconds but you know as
we scale out the difference gets bigger
and bigger and bigger the Google News
data set that was two hundred thousand
word vectors from Google News took four
and a half hours 40s you need to do you
met that in 14 minutes so you know in
terms of speeding scale up
it's like 3 X 13 X 11 X 19 X the larger
the data seat you get the more speed-up
you're getting it's a synthetic ly
faster so for all three million word
vectors from that Google News data set
you manage to do that in just a couple
of hours it took t-sne several days to
run all right so we're next so the key
here is that given the mathematical
foundation we have a whole bunch of
mathematical rigor that tells us how to
do everything and describes good theory
a number of options start opening up for
being able to do more than what t-sne
did or sorry a standard dimensional
reduction techniques can do so we can
embed new unseen points into an existing
embedding so if we have our profession
in this train data see it we can take
the test set and embed that into the
existing and getting just fine that
means you can implement this transform
method as part of any scalar and
pipeline and use it as part of standard
machine learning techniques rather than
just as a visualization tool and here's
a fun one
this was actually why I originally
started working on you map I had an idea
for how to do this and it I ended up
creating units trying to get the theory
right to be able to do this make use of
labels for supervised dimensional
reduction so here's a fun thing
fashion interest comes with labels
although the images are labeled I'd like
to do a dimensional reduction that
understood what those labels were and
yet still did something meaningful
so here's fashion in this embedded by
you met using that label information so
now even those classes that were
previously muddied and mixed together it
splits legs out perfectly because we
gave it the label information so it
knows how to split them apart but it
still captured the internal structure of
all those but from pieces the the green
and light orange here so has that weird
banding structure that was actually
evident in the original plot and
everything works just as it would and
we've still captured the global
structure as well the relative position
of the different clumps is pretty much
the same
so given the label information we can
actually embed even more informatively
and better yet we can combine both of
those things why not do both what if we
had an embedding into a metric space
using label information and then have
some new unlabeled points can we embed
those into that space so yes we can
here's the fashion in this training data
set embedded using the label information
so that all the classes are very cleanly
split out and then I can take the test
set and embed that using the same
technique as before and there are some
errors there you know if there's some
red mixed in with the green but it
mostly did a really good job and if you
compare that with triplet networks which
are someone's current state of the art
for something like metric learning it
compares pretty favorably while triplet
networks do a pretty reasonable job they
have some of the same sorts of errors
that the human approach was doing but
what you Matt did was it still captured
the internal structure of all of those
different classes and that internal
interesting fine detail structure which
the triplet networks just don't do now
you can think of using that label
information is adding one categorical
variable the label in theory that's no
it's no harder to just add in a whole
bunch more so in fact we can combine
spaces with different metrics so if I
have some continuous data and some
categorical data I already combined
those that was the label information I
could have continuous data as long as I
can measure a distance it might be
ordinal I could use a Harrison metric if
I have sparse Levenstein I could do
string distance there's all sorts of
things as long as you can measure a
distance you can fold these things
together so as long as you can provide a
metric for the data type you met can
combine them together with other data
types so at least in principle I haven't
written to all the code to do this yet
you met four pandas dataframes would
just work you have a general pandas out
of frame with general data and as long
as you can tell it
how to measure distance for each of
those different data type columns
it'll just embed all of them into a
single vector space in a convenient way
and you can visualize generic data
frames so conclusions PCA is
interpreting dimension reduction that's
the thing to take away that measure of
maximal variance for your prototype
directions that means when you plot a
PCA plot the dimension the axes actually
mean something those are the directions
of maximal variance and that's a really
important thing interpretative machine
learning matters and if you need an
interpreter with dimensional reduction
PCA is the way to go
tcd is just awesome you map is even more
awesome and there's still a whole lot
more to do on all of these things I'm
just getting started with some of these
further ideas that we can work on so
collaborators are welcome if you're
interested come and talk to me
afterwards or get a hold of me file an
issue on github or reach me on Twitter
and we can try and work together to
extend this even further thank you
[Applause]
in practice the uniform distribution
assumption can be converted into a means
to approximate the volume form of the
manifold and under suitable assumptions
given the volume form you can actually
derive the complete Roumania metric
local to that data point I mean it
varies across as you go but it's really
a matter of essentially approximating
the volume form given the distribution
of data that you have yeah yes
the kind of rasterizing it when you
through the dimensionality reduction
something like that what the article is
for use of countenance is that you
actually retain the positional
information does that matter to you lose
information or how do you get around
that confidence would definitely
preserve more information I mean we're
talking about image data there and yes
the relative position like I'm losing
the vertical relative positioning when I
unfolded into it's a one victor and I
would say the interesting thing is that
even without anything as fancy as
confidence we can recover a huge amount
of information about the actual
structure regardless so cold knits would
manage to come up with things you will
not manage to get out of this but on the
other hand you could pair this with
confidence have a convolutional net and
just strip off the last few layers that
gives you a E and imbedding and then you
can embed that down to two dimensions
with you map further so I've seen for
example people have used t city and you
met to take images and a bit images into
two dimensions using a layers of
convolutional net as as sort of an
intermediate step I have a theoretical
way that that can be done I have not
worked through sorry I have not worked
through all the details to ensure that
that can actually work in practice but
if you're interested come discuss with
me later and maybe you can implement it
[Music]
so in that particular case where where I
had the the coats and the shoes and the
dresses I'm literally taking the image
and just stretching it out into a victor
and measuring Euclidean distance between
those vectors which as the the other
person know
you know convolutional nets will do a
whole lot more for you than that what's
remarkable is how much can be achieved
with something as simple as this if you
pair it with convolutional nets that
would give you sort of more interesting
ways to measure distance that take some
of those sorts of factors into account
[Music]
which one this one you mean in terms of
what the axes mean no no no that's
explicitly what you don't get with both
t-sne or you map
um PCA has interpretive axes the X YZ
means something with these approaches
these X's have no meaning they're just
if I put the data down into two
dimensions this is a way that would make
it look as close as possible to the the
actual structure of the data but the
axes have no inherent meaning it's just
a yeah so that actually leads us to one
of the other questions which was could I
take something in the latent space and
find the original data that would
correspond to that and that's presuming
one had that algorithm in place that's
how you that's essentially one way that
you would do it you would look at the
sort of points in the region of pants
and say well what do these look like in
the high initial space and then you
basically do an analysis on the
generated data of that for what are the
features of this that are leading to
this so it's a non-trivial process at
this stage but it's conceivable
when it's just a label the measure of
categorical distance is basically well
if you had a suite of categories you
could use jacquard or dice when you have
a single category you get any distance 0
when the categories match at a distance
of pick a number when the categories
differ and it's just just that there's
really only a couple distances could you
give more information in terms of the
feature space
how many features can you have cuz
they're not even with HDTV scan just the
performance right if you have too many
features that dimensionality yeah I have
successfully run unit on something with
50,000 features sparse data don't dance
but it will run with sparse matrices so
you can go up pretty high dimensional
it's slower as soon as you have the
sparse but it's still manageable and you
can run it and so actually the the other
side of that coin is what dimension are
you projecting into so when you're
working with t-sne you can project out
into two dimensions if you project to
three dimensions that's rather more
expensive and you generally can't
project to four dimensions and be it
into four dimensions or anything much
higher than that this is way too
computationally taxing it's exponential
in cost and embedding dimension for
t-sne you Methos linear in cost for
embedding dimensions so you can embed
into 20 30 50 dimensional space and then
cluster there and I've seen people do
that where they decided that in fact 12
inventions or so is the best embedding
dimension to go to because they wanted
to do clustering after that questions
I have naught that would be intriguing
we should definitely chat later if you
if you have such data so that maybe
maybe we'll try to wrap up I want to
also comment that well well Lee Lim says
that he's not a program he's a
mathematician I'd like to say that from
what I've seen and some of the other
work that he's done he's actually an
exceptionally good programmer or
developer right but with that lets thank
you living it for making a trip
[Applause]